as Nick ly push down low for Colton Caro the
defenseman up on the play back for Ley tyu
hich whips one off jari when you can when
seven nothing and Sid's not on the score
sheet that tells you he doing something right
look out L back in and Champs in front great
save jari Robin S Point Blank Brandon sad as
he takes a beautiful dish from sh and Graves
back down low gel after that knocked away
from him here's Graves for Rael canel out
with it stick check by hord bounces up in the
air Crosby right to it picks it back up how
about that download toel gel a drive deflected
off the crossbar back and back we went what a
chance for Jake gensel the knuckle Puck off the
butt of Thomas Riley Smith the pass knocked down
and St Louis Works back up ice it's perunovich
and he lift it deep into the penguin Zone look
out weird bounce on jari makes the save here's
Robert Thomas back in for the blues Co naic's
pass Knocked Down by Crosby who's feeling it
early here's Crosby takes it ahead drops it for
Carlson Rael to the net and getting a piece with
hper fed to KR connects to Kyu closed by Ellen
Thomas dropping it for K snapshot jar the
blocker Sav Jake neighbors getting for
traffic there unable to get the puck on goldo
Shen back to it up top for perunovich across a
one-time from leny and jari sees it stops IT and
hangs on not too many of them can move laterally
once they get locked when they're locked down
they're big as they they take up a lot of net
right makes a save there on Chris lank sad
quick clear good stick Marcus Pon otherwise
Jake neighbors was gone back in come the pens
Rael his snapshot is gloved by hord Malin for
Riley Smith couldn't keep it in bounces back
out the center for rule one of his 12 NHL goals
has come against the St Louis Blues Malin
back in after it he's got o Conor Feats him
scars Drew o Conor going upstairs and the
Penguins open up the scoring one nothing
let's start with the outlet pass and they
get it to a little bumper play by Riley
Smith if Genny Malin trusted that Smith
was going to bump this Puck Off the Wall
he picks it up but the key here is Drew
o Conor made a little stutter step he
pulled up a little bit kyou for Thomas
over the line in front he's got boot n
it's jar a great save and he hangs on and
another opportunity and Tristan jar shut it
down penguins come back in Pon nice feed
Crosby skate the stick backhander in front
gel a chance hope for the save Bo in
comes in for Pittsburgh while Terry
Poon in wraps it around trades
one timer save H for there's no
rebound Thomas for Krug back to Braden Shen
again to Krug here's kyou Thomas a shot he
scores great Puck Movement by the blues and
Thomas has tied this game at one on a power play
goal oh that's the one thing you do not want to
happen as a penalty killer that passed the seam
pass you know this is something that Edington uses
with Leon dry Sidle all the time on the other side
of the ice as a left hand shot Thomas the right
hand Shot opens up for that one timer and even
though it's from a bit of a difficult angle
because he's a right-hand shot and kyou just
puts it right on the table gensel for Carlson
pushing it down low Raquel against so but they
score fgny Malin to flex it in and malin's got two
points tonight and the Pens have a 2-1 lead on a
PPG an Hest game you take an undisciplined
penalty I told you you got to make him play
and the Penguins make him pay big time here
Jake gentel and usually this is a spot that
Sydney Crosby has right that back door it goes off
the skate of aenny Malin no kicking motion this
one's going to count folks off the right skate of
guiney Malin and Jake had to make that pass hard
throw Conor to the Pucket Center puts it Forward
Smith's got a chance couldn't finish it a puck
was bobbling on him and H for covers trying to get
back on Riley Smith got to stick in there at the
last second maybe not enough for a penalty but
Rael pumps it to center gensel around Paro he's
gone save by Hur with the glove it left him in
his dust and then everything slowed down Carlson
back hands it to the slot picked off Tory KW short
hand and he's got Capital with him and Sun Chris
crw save JY with the left leg and it Springs the
pens back up ice on this backand there's there's
zero absolute zero chance of this happening
what a save by Tristan jar to keep this a 2-1
game Carter out to Center nol aari who
was productive in a brief stint with
the Blues last season before being traded
to Toronto centering in for Carter scores
oh you'll love to see the depth production
and big Jeff Carter's got a huge one tonight
3-1 pin one goal game your fourth line get
the hard hat on get the work boots on go
to work on your four check and then get that
baby to the net and big Jeff Carter heavy on
the stick shovels it past poer Who's down a
little h on is making it hard for the blues
to enter comes to bich off iron there
the break you're were looking for right
there guy that shot again in this hockey
game as the Penguins got a little bit too
spread out and Tristy jar good positioning
maybe influenced that shot a little bit
but it comes to Chad rle he's pressured by
Captain Neighbors after it as well Graves
tries to clear kept in by by perovich the horn
is out perovich is shot is tipped in desp cing
just as that St Louis power play expires he's
made this a one-goal game it's 3-2 I thought it
was a really good job by Chad ridle the deflection
there by Kasper Ka and as he got positioning past
Ryan Graves I think if Graves turns around
and takes Captain is not watching the point
maybe you have a different outcome here but I
think St Louis is throwing a lot of pucks from
Bad angles at the feet KY what a save jar might
have caught the iron yeah Jordan Kyu such great
hands to take it to the net makes a little fed
off move around Sammy bla back to the point for
KW Snapp her off the post ji never saw it the
pens tap it to Center oh boy penguins in front
3-2 Carlon in the loose Puck launches
it Forward knocked down by gel whips it
ahead Crow's after it he comes up with the Pucket
scores great Hustle by Eric Carlon they get
to a loose Puck make a Pass to Jake gensel and
Jake just throws an aerial Puck up into a space
where no Sid can go get it and sit so masterful
using his feet oh it's a festive atmosphere
here in Pittsburgh and they're on their feet
showing the appreciation of this effort here
tonight what a great crowd two-point Party
on Fifth Avenue the Penguins 42 winners over
the St Louis Clues they have won two straight